warden lacy he had always thought the  devil was just a metaphor but now he  knew the devil was a boy there is a lot  of history in this town not all that  good  I'm your lawyer now if you've got no  name - got no charge no crime no story  this town the suffering you wonder where  was God bad [ __ ] happens here because  bad people know you're safe here  at the cover story the real scoop you  tell me did you  I'm telling you there is something wrong  with that kid I did my part I am done  are they goofy exists all you're doing  out knows war is that more than anyway  why did you ask for me  that's what God told me never again let  him see the light of day  [Music]